you i'm talking to you probably have a
great idea
and i think you should turn it into a
reality and you know what
squarespace can help you do that they
make it easier than ever
to launch whatever your passion project
is i'm sure you got one
or you're thinking about getting one and
when you get one they're going to help
you out with it do you want to showcase
your work do you want to sell products
of any kind
they can help you with beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about
anything so you can easily make a
beautiful website by yourself
but if you get stuck guess what they
have a 24 7
24 7 award-winning customer support
system that's there to help you out
go to squarespace.com grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use that offer code grace save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain i dare you
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig i'm very excited for you to
listen and watch today's episode with
naomi
ekperrigan or as you might know her
black dress or black dress comedy
on twitter and instagram she is so
wonderful
i can't get over how lovely of a
conversation
it was to have with her we talk about
her
trials tribulations successes and
failures
all surrounding uh trader joe's and
hopefully
a future sponsorship that trader joe's
offers her because she's
mr joe doing you a huge service
we also talk about her entering into
comedy
improv stand up what did that look like
for her and
how she's truly handling the pandemi as
she is so wonderfully
nicknamed it also she's given me
true valid pure reason to start watching
buffy for someone that
hasn't dipped my toe in that uh soap
opera
vamp is it bad vampire uh or i'm
sure forget the last part but this is a
really great conversation enjoy
naomi on not too deep
[Music]
naomi thank you for being here um you
are
truly a queen of many things but in
particular
one of my favorite things is your
ability to nickname
really tragic events in a very cute way
the fact that you say pandemi every time
gets me i love it it makes it much more
palatable i think
yes we're trying to add a sense of
whimsy to the crumbling
feeling yes uh my my other
uh question concern thought is
uh has trader joe's reached out to
sponsor you in any type of way
at this point grace grace after
everything
i have said about them okay as an
institution as a place where i go for
sustenance
i haven't heard of goddamn work really
because you've recently had a very
engaging saga
happen in your home um how did it can
you explain to people that don't
know what's go what has transpired what
happened
yes yes i will relive it for you because
i do consider this to be a safe space
okay it's a great space where i can
process um
so you know i am really like taking
this coke the cocoa very seriously okay
and i'm not leaving the house i'm like i
we go me and my fiance we go grocery
shopping like once a month like out to
the store
and that's considered thank you and we
have to go to tj's
because that is like the one place that
refuses to instacart or
deliver or curbside pickup and i need my
cereals
okay i'm very brand loyal to cereals
so we go and when we go it's a big deal
you know trader joe's look even before a
pandemic the place was lawless
okay because we're all there because
we're broke but want to be healthy
yeah it's like both an entitled but a
scrappy group yes
can you imagine i just think of the
musical rent if it was written now
would incorporate a scene in trader
joe's at some point
yes yes literally uh seasons of hummus
so we go and it's like packed and you
know we go with a list we want to get in
and out
and again because it's once a month i
mean we're loading up we each get
a cart yeah you prepared honey
i'm like you take frozen i'm getting the
project
and so we have a whole system so we get
everything get out
you know and like you come home with
everything and then of course you gotta
disinfect it all right you gotta wipe it
down you gotta wash the veggies
it's a process it's a process so by the
time that happens like
we went shopping at 11am we're done by
two
doing all that and then at 5 00 pm
our electricity goes out
when i tell you this is the most full
our fridge and freezer had been like
in a month you know what i mean like
yeah laughable
the tetris we had to do to fit
everything and you're looking at it like
this is opulence like we
have provided for ourselves we've hunted
and gathered at the same time
i think we are thriving do you know
we've got two flavors of greek yogurt
okay coming through with soft cheeses
a breathing a mops baby give us a monty
parmesan we're going from soft to heart
we've got a whole
[ __ ] cheese hooray
and so when that when that power went
out dude
it was like and we literally were just
like okay
okay like it'll come back yeah this is
the team
it was and we looked online and it said
you had four hours
for like dairy in particular right oh
wait so you went online and you looked
up
how long can these items last without
refrigeration okay yes like if the
electricity how long of course it was
like don't open the fridge don't open
the freezer you know
let it all hold the cold and it said
four hours so we were like okay
okay well don't worry don't worry until
hour before don't worry
i'm in my upper register yeah
meanwhile luckily you know the electric
the water and power they came within the
hour okay so this happened at five they
were there by six so we're like okay
getting handled the electricity did not
come back on until 1 30 a.m
a.m yes so that was eight and a half
hours girl oh no and they were working
on it the whole time like
at one point because like literally
there was a point at which
one truck comes then a second truck
comes then the second truck
leads and a third truck comes it was
like one of those like
we're gonna need a bigger boat yeah yeah
it was like
and i was like oh [ __ ] oh no what's
happening
and so you know we were very very
like you know to get that haul and to
get this stuff
and also stuff like this happens of
course but you know
it's like we're already in a goddamn pan
yeah stuff like this shouldn't happen
day
110 in a pandemic when you've already
you've done your responsible due
diligence of you know spacing out your
trips every
30 to 40 days like you're not going
every day yeah
that is uh wild
so it all all the power everything's
working everything's okay now
did you lose any uh okay okay this was
it so yeah i
am more inclined to just take a bite of
cheese and see what happens to my
to my butt yeah at this point you guys
are
you know each other well enough you've
been stuck with each other well enough
that you can
take a chance yeah whereas andy my
betrothed
he's like i'm not willing to he's like i
don't
know i can't even risk being physically
uncomfortable there's like already too
much going on
yeah so so yesterday i did have a little
bit of that brie
with some crackers so far so good okay
okay so you become your own science
experiment basically at this point
aren't we all doctors at this point a
hundred percent with everything we've
been reading i'm always like the viral
load and how fast
does it travel indoors it's like and
then the dogs can get it maybe
i guess or supposedly who knows no no no
i know well you have you have a sweet
sweet pup
mabel wow grace for you to just come in
here and know the name of my daughter
i've done a lot of research i've done
like a very
kind of um borderline stalkerish amount
of
research on you so but mabel mabel
is such a sweetie what is the can i
ask the origin story of mabel so we
have not even had her a year yet um we
already
we got her august 30th of last year okay
we already had two cats
and the cats were andy's when we first
got together
and i love cats i love animals but i
think we moved to la about three years
ago
and i was like i want one that's mine
yeah you know because i feel like the
cats are his
and i want an animal that loves me of
course
and then l.a you know was so sunny and
warm it makes it seem easy to have a dog
right so we you know so last year i was
like i was like come on let's do it we
moved into an apartment we like you know
we feel like we have a little more room
and it was like i was like i'm ready i'm
ready to be a mother and so
we went and we had to do a whole thing
because again we have the cat so we went
to
lang foundation shout out to lang
foundation
okay our rescue and they will do cat
testing
so if you want a dog they also have cats
and they will like we're like hey we
have cats can we see how this dog goes
they will bring their dog into a room
with like a bunch of their cats
i've never heard of that before that's
super cool
yeah so she it was funny because they
were like
she didn't fail but she
didn't like she the perfect response is
a dog who does not care
right ideally the dog literally just
like lets the cats kind of roam around
mabel she didn't want to fight she
didn't start anything
but she was very into sniffing their
butts in a way that was invasive
okay
you can't do that in 2019
you have honey okay you have got to
believe
cats and so so when we brought her home
we did a whole dramatic like
for a month they were not in the same
place like she lived in our bedroom for
a month
so she didn't even know that they
existed or like kinda could tell
they smell each other right like they
can sense it something's going down and
then you would like
slowly let them see each other through a
gate and stuff we bought a baby gate a
baby gate i told you i'm a mother
that's great um and then
and so now so far so good like you know
she doesn't do anything
she is like a narc i do believe mabel
would work for the police
because if anything is happening
like if the cats are wrestling or even
if andy and i like are kissing
she will bark she like comes over and
barks like break it up
so she's like a professional chaperone
yeah she's like a
a middle school dance chaperone like six
feet six feet
keep your distance oh my gosh should i
start calling her sister mary mabel
oh it's
it's obvious uh so okay
you you in your stand up you talk about
andy a lot you guys have obviously a
very beautiful relationship
what and you guys host a podcast
together
what was the like uh the
crossing of the line of being like we
both are comedians we both do our thing
let's work together
now oh girl oh girl
the crossing of the line is living
together
and talking about everything yeah you
know what'll happen with
just any like comedy friends or creative
friends you know how it's like y'all
talk about something and it's like yep
should we do this together yeah or like
this is both of our idea i guess like
that's that's kind of how it happened in
a way because
couples therapy started as a live show
on the pod
you know we have comics who are close to
sets together and that was a live
version now of course in quarantine
we're doing interviews we're answering
relationship questions it's like
i love it i'm like i also really
appreciate the podcast more now because
it's my way to interact with humans
yeah i don't know if you feel that if
you're like people a hundred percent
like being able to have this
conversation and this zoom
like interaction like we'll uh i'll be
fine for the rest of the week now
like i'll be good i have my and i have
my socializing down today
right exactly yeah so it's so basically
we started as a live show because we
realized oh we know a lot of comics and
people who are like a couple or not and
we tried it
and then i feel like the decision to be
a podcast is you look to la
and i don't know about you but when i
moved here i received a letter from the
los angeles podcast council
saying i had it saying i had 180 days to
establish my podcast
this is very true very true
so we're like we gotta do something
we're gonna do them before they kick us
out
you guys also uh you stream on twitch
right while you podcast yes every
wednesday
at two o'clock uh pacific we just do
like an hour sometimes we'll have
you know duos kind of like the live show
but yeah a lot of times just me and andy
and it's really fun we have a lot of
people watching like we're the ctq which
is the couple's therapy quarantine crew
so it's like we literally like people
every week and it's like and people in
the chat talk to each other like they're
friends now
oh that's great like an actual community
that's
really sweet and so how
uh so you work in entertainment comedian
actress you've been doing a lot of
wonderful things
in quarantine what is like uh if there
is
a regular day like for you oh
great i know well this is me secretly
just wanting to hear what other people
are doing so i don't feel so
[ __ ] alone and weird oh i'll be
honest with you okay
okay space now all right so
9 9 30 i wake up no matter what
time i've gone to bed i now have this
internal clock from having the dog
i get up i do the morning walks so i'm
gonna i take her out
luckily it feels like in quarantine
she's become a lazy girl
um we used to do a 20 30 minute walk in
the morning
now she goes to one end of the block
does her business we come back
she sits on the stoop oh so girl i'm
into you
i appreciate the efficiency so efficient
in the morning
like so you know we sit out 15 minutes
come back in
feeder you know um take your lexapro
take your wellbutrin um
then really you know then
oh i'm hungry i wake up so hungry and
then
i'll usually either have my trader joe's
vanilla almond just the cluster cereal
all right a real hearty bowl a party
bowl
and then usually honey that'll take a
lot out of me all right just eating that
digesting that yeah now
you go back to bed all right so now
you're at about you're at about 10
30 and you want to just lay down all
right
i think that's a wildly overlooked but
like deeply important
thing to do is to have a late morning
lie down thank you so much
thank you so much i see you
you're seeing me for holding me in
awareness
and then that'll bring us 12 31. you
know
at which point sure sure
write a little something uh whether that
be an email or
a tweet or or a strongly worded yelp
review justice
flowing the fingers going yeah get the
fingers
going and then like
i don't know like i you know it's not
the same like some i have been writing
some stuff so you know if i'm like okay
i want to get this done
i've i've accepted i work in short
bursts
you know like i can't beat myself up
because i'm like you didn't finish today
i do way better in short bursts i don't
know about you like you've written a
book
like what was your you know like that's
the same thing
i i work the same way and i'm i'm happy
to hear you say that that like
if uh memory and i always talk about how
we work on like reward based systems of
like
if i work for a one hour straight i can
watch this garbage television
show for 45 minutes and then i can go
back but that's
yeah i have to recognize that i cannot
work consistently throughout the course
of a day i have to work like you said in
small bursts
yes so i'm going to work myself up to it
so now i've started to accept okay you
know what this net you gotta you gotta
ramp into it you gotta power up
and your power down so i'm just
zigzagging honey i'm zigzagging
and then like four and then around like
three or four
that's when i come to andy and i go what
are we having for dinner you know
that's that's if i'm like being good
wait until three or four normally honey
i wake up and i'm like what are we
having for dinner
backwards backwards calorically
calorically
and then like i usually like five or six
right we walk the dog again and that's
like a long walk it's like cool outside
i'm like oh
nature humanity wonderful and then
honey i come back if that's 6 30 i'm
like
you've done your best that's your full
day you're off the clock
at night i don't work at night um i'm
not a night out like i stay up
but i'm not a um i don't have like
creative juices at midnight
right right right yeah totally no
that's what i used to be that kind of
person that i would think that like
the afternoon late afternoon tonight is
like where i got my best ideas and i
could work because
i'm my own boss and i work from home so
like uh
you know regular work schedule doesn't
apply to me and so i can
but now same with you i have to like get
it done early in the day and then by
like five or six i'm like
we did a day we deserve a night how
wonderful you walk out
you gotta talk totally 5 30. 100
um okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back uh i have so many
questions about you you've had braces
twice um
and i need to know about your
relationship with social media because i
think it's really beautiful and
people need to know about it so we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
you're damn right we have support from
squarespace today because i'm sure you
have a dream
that you'd like to turn into a reality
and they can help you out with that they
make it easier than ever
to launch your passion project or your
your quarantine
project we all got one i'm sure do you
want to start a new business do you want
to showcase your work do you want to
publish some content
do you want to sell some products or
more squarespace is the tool for you
they have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers
and the ability to customize just about
anything it's true just about anything
with a few clicks
you can easily make a beautiful website
by yourself and they have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell
anything online make that money and
analytics that will help you grow your
site
in real time everything is optimized for
mobile
right out of the box there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever
don't know what that means but you don't
have to know what it means because you
don't have to do it
and if you do need help you can get it
from their 24 7 award-winning customer
support they empower millions of people
designers lawyers artists games
restaurants gyms
they help them all turn great ideas into
something real and now they can help you
if you go to squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you are
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com
grace offer code grace
okay let's jump back into it okay you've
had braces twice
uh-huh that is a fact um how
how why when okay honey all right the
first time
and if this is a sensitive subject we
can move on but
i only saw this i'm 36 still wearing a
retainer
i this is not sensitive so the first of
my braces was
um i think the fifth grade i started all
that it's like fifth grade i had them
for
three years eight months and 20 days a
thing you remember when you're
13. you know oh i wanted braces so bad
when i would go to the dentist and they
would do like the whatever
x-rays of your teeth i would push my top
teeth over my bottom teeth so hard
and he would say that i had an overbite
and i never got him but
yeah so i'm so sorry your teeth are
perfect
it's all [ __ ] but uh yeah no i i
thought i thought they were so cool i
i loved accessories when i was younger
and i thought that was like
the most beautiful accessories you
wanted like
you want it like sparkly rubber bands
for them like you know the kids who do
that
like rubber bands 100 i wanted the
orange and black for halloween colors i
wanted all of it
yeah i was i hated them always i was
never whimsical
i was just like just literally like get
them off but the reason i remember it
took so long the first time is because
this orthodontist this whole thing was
accelerated orthodontics meaning you
would not have them as long
as normal and that's how damn your four
years yeah that seems wrong
as a theory right penny i was livid
and then so that was like yeah eighth
grade i got them off
and then junior year of college i had
the
junior and senior year i had them for
another two years wow
and that was you know what i mean and it
was like honey
this ain't a fashion show you know what
i mean like
it was humbling yeah
um and even like when i had them after
graduation so like my first job out of
college i'm like on stage
braces wow like how old are you
um but that's very character building i
imagine like you have to create a
confidence
to do that no no no it's why it's
it's what he as i said it keeps you
humble you
it keeps a nice low level self-loathing
that has
that encourages you to keep trying it
encourages you to keep trying so
uh to tangent off of this a little bit
comedy
at what point or was there a point that
you found it interesting or that you
thought this is something i want to
do uh i don't know if it's gonna be a
professional
doing of this but like at what point in
your life were you like this i want i
like laughing i want people to laugh
um it's interesting because i definitely
like didn't know how you made it a job
you know people like
tv was tv was like a magical box it's
like i don't know how you get in there
right right you know it was just like i
was obsessed with it i was into it you
know i also i would say like i was a
child of the 90s where like
there were a lot of black tv shows you
know what i mean if you remember like so
i'm very much like i want to be an actor
and i saw that so i think yeah
definitely
acting before comedy right um because i
still didn't really know
and then it was when i got to college i
was in an improv group
i did college and that was my first time
doing improv you know i didn't really
know
and you know when you get to college and
you're like i'm gonna reinvent myself
so it was like and it was that first you
know month of school yes and people were
in the people
if you're funny you should try out for
improv you know and i was like okay
okay now
and i went and i didn't make it my
freshman year but i got a call back and
it was like
and what i remember so distinctly why i
was like oh i gotta do this was
you know you go in you do your scene or
whatever and then they call the next
people
and we left and i heard them like
laughing and like re-saying what i had
just said in the scene
oh that's cool and that hit me like i
was like
can that happen can we make people do
that
yeah oh that's so cool and that's when i
was like okay i want to do this and so
it really kind of started through
improv and then in doing improv uh
you did improv right yeah i did at the
people's improv theater in new york
yeah so it's like i don't know what you
was like and doing improv i was like
i don't need all these people here it's
like i had to learn i had to
see a little group setting tonight oh no
no no
i'm a solo artist
oh yeah that's kind of how i got to
stand up but you know being from new
york i mean it basically started you
know
bar shows and right you know i think
yeah i saw
throwback thursday photo i think of like
your first open mic
was in california i know it was here of
all places
yeah 2000 2006. yeah
because i was visiting a friend who
lived here
and i tend to do that like when i travel
when i'm away from home i'll take risks
because because my thinking is if i
crash and burn
i'll never be here again you know what i
mean uh
that memory and i have uh when we first
met we also dabbled with the idea of
doing stand-up
it's it's so intimidating to me but we
always said
we were gonna go to new jersey and do it
like an open mic in new jersey because
no one would know how awful we were
yes so i get that i get that mentality
yeah
you get it so my whole thing was you
know we were there in l.a and i was like
and that's the thing i asked i was like
i just want to go to one open mind i
asked her like can we do that and
you know my thinking was i'll finally
bite the bullet and then
if it sucks honey pack a bag get on a
jet plate
so that's that was the first time it
actually it wasn't that bad
you know it was um it was i got some
laughs again it was like
barely an audience i got some laughs but
i do remember the host
like because we stayed for the show
again you know in your early days you're
like do i stay for the whole thing right
here i don't know i'm like i'm really
hungry but i'll say it
and uh i remember the host like saying
you know he's up there he's like oh she
was funny like pointing at me and it was
like
okay okay you know was it like some
bagel it's like i didn't honey it wasn't
like a [ __ ] standing ovation
thunderous applause but it was enough
to know like you can try this and it
won't kill you
and like you might have a little
something totally that's very cool and
also
uh just very i think inspiring whenever
if ever stand-up comedy comes back for
people
when when when when it comes back
absolutely
um okay in incorn team we've all had to
adapt we've all had to adjust
how and your relationship with social
media i think is so beautiful and
wonderful and and effortless
what is your favorite it's great because
i've
been doing this for like 10 years but i
still like freeze up a lot uh
on social media because it's so
inundating but like what's your favorite
social media platform like when you open
your phone what's the first thing
that you were kind of like unconsciously
checking on now it's
instagram and it definitely wasn't just
you know i feel like
initially right being a comic it was all
about twitter you got to do jokes you
got to do jokes
and i was never really that good of that
to me i feel like i'm
just more conversational like i couldn't
really be pithy
you know now we have like what 280
characters i have a little more to work
with
but i certainly could not give you the
world 140
you know and so it wasn't really my
thing and i felt like i don't know how
to use this stuff
and then insta came out and then i was
like it feels weird knowing what
somebody from college just ate for
dinner
and they thought it was too invasive i
didn't know how i like to do it
and it's only i feel like in quarantine
that i've started to kind of like
just say [ __ ] it i feel like i've become
i'm calling myself very
young and online that's what i tell
myself now i go i'm young and online
because i do videos now and i would have
never before um
but it's insta because right as twitter
became more of a political platform
yeah insta i can curate honey i can
curate
i follow animal rescues i follow
babies yeah this is what i was gonna ask
what is your like
uh if you have recommendations on what
what do you follow
okay look i love to honey i open it up i
need my social media to not make me feel
like crap right yeah so follow mayday
rescue
m-a-e-d-a-y okay little dogs here in los
angeles
wonderful i follow uh cat lovers club
come on what are they up to what are
they doing
i follow an array of zoos bronx zoo san
diego zoo
the zoos are always having fun they're
instagrams i saw a lovely dolphin show
grace
i haven't even thought about that entire
branch of instagram thank you
for letting me know you can watch a
dolphin show at home
sit in the house watch a dolphin show
this is quarantine baby it's quarantine
okay what are you guys watching on
tv movies like what's your go-to now are
you binging anything
so you know i
like terrible television okay
i i no no you like you watch the
housewives
that's like quote-unquote terrible but
there's a cultural conversation around
it
i'm watching shark week grace uh shark
week
okay like old shark weeks yes
yes shark week 2017
shark week 2018. amazing are you are you
learning things
is that okay
because you know i also mostly i love
true crime and so i think my
shark week in a way has been a pivot to
nature's true crime
you know what i mean watching shark week
is to be watching predators at work
and that's just what i'm into um but
i've also been
i like a lot of like give me like a
british procedural
like a mystery like something we're
watching one on netflix now called
gary hodgy it's like japan and london
and geary means duty and [ __ ] means
shame
and it's like a cop and he's got to get
his brother who's working for the yakuza
and he's gone to london and it's like
wow the drama
and this is uh this is scripted yes and
it's on netflix and it's just like
i like the british shows because they
don't do as many episodes you know what
i mean like they get in and out
yeah it's eight one hour episodes
like you watch the first episode you
feel like you've had a whole season
worth of experience
you know everything that happened i'm
telling you
i got that's my new job okay okay are
you
into uh like unsolved mysteries or
things like that
grace yeah i would like you to solve
them
unsolved i know there is a little bit of
blue balls at the end of the episode
because
i wanna i wanna wrap it up and i to know
that there's closure on this
horrific experience that we've all gone
through now i
need closure like i don't watch you know
as a trooper i feel like i'm obviously
just impressed upon people i don't watch
true crime for
gore like i'm not here to just hear
about someone being
hurt it's more i'm interested in the
process of finding who did it like i'm
very into the
you know the system the justice system
and cups and like what they do and what
they don't do
and all that kind of stuff 100 i want to
watch for and there's nothing i hate
more especially some of my murder
podcasts honey
yeah i have this one podcast
case file true crime episodes are
anywhere from one hour to like
two hour 20. okay whoa okay there's
nothing i
hate more than listening to an episode
and figuring out
two [ __ ] hours they ain't found a
[ __ ]
you gotta tell me up top cause that was
a waste of my time
oh no yeah that's horrible at least
unsolved mysteries
like you know what you're getting into
like it's your fault if you think that
this is gonna wrap up
in a with a bow um if you like that kind
of stuff i would recommend
wrong man i don't know if you it's on
stars
i think but it's also on like amazon
prime or whatever
and it's like this it's it's like this
ragtag
group of like retired fbi interrogators
and like cops and things
and they've been hired to investigate
these uh and they work i think in tandem
with the innocence project
and they work to kind of reinvestigate
these people that have been imprisoned
and it's like this
it's like this team of avengers but
they're doing like real
world like they they're going to these
small towns they're talking to the cops
that handle these cases
they're showing all the holes in the
case they're showing all the bad
behavior of investigators and cops
it is so but it also it a lot of the
narratives don't wrap up well but they
do a great job of exposing all of like
the uh missteps that happened in the
actual like investigation which is so
wonderful
i love when people that are lazy and bad
at their jobs get called out for it
it's so it's very satisfying in these
trying times to watch that happen so
i highly recommend that for you guys
thank you you're looking for stuff thank
you
that's good grace thank you of course
you're absolutely welcome
what i mean you guys are probably oh
okay
here's my question for you uh you got
you said couples therapy is the
live show turned podcast that you host
with your fiance husband beyonce
yes we've been together ten years so i
uh
will say husband entertain
interchangeably okay is there is there
wedding plans oh totes there are going
to be wedding plans and then we have
verona like
literally march 5th i looked at a venue
in new york and i came back to la and i
was like andy i think this is the one
and we were emailing and the lady of
course was trying to get that down
payment
and then as soon as the you know i was
like we just gotta wait we can't even
at least you didn't put the down payment
down exactly
but there though so there's stuff to
look forward to as soon as all oh sure
we've all got a little something to look
forward to totally but you guys have
been giving out
advice for couples in various forms
so i would wonder what's your um
major piece of advice for these couples
the first couple uh is the obamas
okay my number one piece of advice to
the obamas is relax
all right i think you both need to buy a
pair of sweatpants
you need to sit on a couch for a solid
two hours
i don't think they sit down for more
than 15 minutes i
think that it would be good for them to
just sink into each other
just honey
[Applause]
lounge lounge
i love that that's my advice okay what
is your advice for
elon musk and grimes stop it
stop it that's it that's it
that's perfect okay last couple kermit
and miss piggy
well you know what we often say believe
women however i feel
that miss piggy um she
she has to accept boundaries she has to
accept boundaries
because she's beautiful she has options
she
doesn't have to chase it grace i always
say anyone worth your time will never
have to be convinced
okay that's what i say that's a
beautiful advice
and and that honey is what i have to say
for miss piggy yeah i have to tell
honey first of all maybe change your
last name that might be affecting your
self-esteem all right
and then just you know find someone who
is here for the thickness
i love that okay we're gonna take one
last break when we get back we have a
bunch of twitter questions for you
that um some are very real and wonderful
and some of them
are not so we'll be right back with more
not too deep
[Music]
today we have support from better help
online counseling we are living in
extraordinary times as you all
know and have experienced and if you are
struggling with stress anxiety or
depression you are not
alone not even a little bit better help
offers online licensed professional
counselors who are trained to listen
and help their counselors specialize in
many areas including relationship
conflict
anxiety depression loss trauma and more
and you'll securely connect with your
counselor in a safe confidential online
environment
all you do is you fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your needs
and you get matched with the counselor
in under 48
hours and from there you can easily
schedule secure video or phone sessions
with your therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages i have
a bunch of friends who have used
betterhelp and they love it and the
ability to
exchange messages at any points that you
are
feeling the need to reach out is such a
wonderful thing
such a bonus such a great luxury to have
with using better help and
if for any reason you're unhelped
unhappy with your counselor you can
request a new one
anytime at no additional charge
betterhelp is an affordable option and
you guys will get 10
off your first month with the discount
code grace
join over one million people who are
already using betterhelp
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they're actually
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
get started today at betterhelp.com
grace
that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
grace to talk to a therapist online and
get help
okay we're back in naomi before we get
to
all these twitter questions i'm going to
ask you the two questions i ask every
single guest that is on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti
at wow
and this is with the understanding that
your answer you can change on a regular
basis but uh it's
today who in your mind is someone that
you'd love to throw cold spaghetti at
it's so interesting you say that you
know i hate to get political but i
really want to throw cold
spaghetti on kellyanne conway there's
something about her even though she's
like not
essential of a figure anymore she still
works my nerve
it's wild yeah there's something um
there's so much effort put into being so
evil that it's so unnerving to me
yes yes and there's also just something
about you know the discomfort of
cold spaghetti yes but also like is it a
salt
no i'm off the hook and that's what i
like
that's what i like about it i'm with you
okay
the other question that i ask every
single guest on the podcast is to tell
us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or a
close or close call but you can only use
three words or small phrases so
for instance for instance mine is a
college jogging
front lawn okay okay
uh lexapro
side effects laundry and unit
wow we've definitely never heard uh
those a string of words for this answer
paints a very um specific picture
thank you i also love that you had them
in mind immediately after the question
was asked because sometimes people are
like
i don't that's never happened to me well
grace it was
somewhat recent okay that's why
it's fresh i get it uh
okay let's get to these twitter
questions um
first one favorite add-in to mac and
cheese
oh wow okay bacon peas
bacon and peas together yes i'm creating
more of a if you think about it a
carbonara
yeah that feels about the egg i love the
bacon and a pea
oh that's wonderful um okay someone
wants to know ask her to just geek out
about buffy for a bit are you a big
i because i've never watched buffy
i know so it's i i would ask you to
explain to someone like me that's never
dipped my toe in that pond like why i
should okay were you an angsty teen at
all did you feel not understood did you
have
bigger dreams than your small town would
let you have
yes i felt like i was i was trapped in a
small town
yes penny you're a slayer you're a
slayer we're
all a slayer and buffy captures a moment
in time now to be fair yes i was
watching in seventh grade right
so i do have an attachment but buffy is
a story of a girl
in a tiny town who has to face every
hurdle you can imagine
and it's just it's this also a perfect
eye love for me that shows very form is
it is a genre meld right because it's
like
fantasy sci-fi-ish right
but then really funny and then also a
real heavy drama it pretty much
takes the drama it takes high school and
all its angst and drama
and just heightens it to the level of
people being actual monsters you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah yeah high
school
high school um on crack wow so like
terrifying like the allegory is just
like in your face
okay that's cool and it's fun and it's
cute and honestly we're in quarantine
honey what else are you doing
it has seven seasons my boyfriend just
introduced me to lost
i've never watched lost before i've
never watched lost are you liking it
it is a lot they definitely are lost
and they are not where they are supposed
to be
uh but it is yeah it's it's
it's wild to know that i guess when it
came out like 2003
2004 crazy that like it was taken so
seriously and it is sci-fi
which i didn't realize at first i
thought it was just kind of
i don't know invention thriller
adventure thriller-ish but yeah
yeah it's and it's very like
unapologetically soap opera
yeah a bit which is what i imagined
buffy to be
but oh yeah be soapy yeah okay okay okay
i mean yeah now is the time to catch up
on all of these
um okay someone wants to know what is
your favorite type
of bean type of bean
type of bean wow
huh difficult question refried
okay that's a great answer i'm really
fried
have you ever eaten refried beans cold
like straight from the can no no no no
okay
no so so you haven't reached that level
of depression here
[Laughter]
wow yeah it's uh i mean they're not the
worst they they do the trick
uh okay someone wants to know
what book show or film do you just
know you could have written ten times
better
huh book show or film that is tough
that is time or is there a book show or
film that you
i guess i'll rephrase wish that you
could have been a part of writing
yeah i wish i could have been a part of
writing um you know what i love
and i mean it's all kind of coming
together a piece shaun of the dead
oh i've never seen that oh grace so good
okay i'm getting a lot of great
recommendations from this podcast
you got it shauna did to me and
especially when it came out it was just
so um funny and good
and like the way it shot and everything
about it is like i just wish i was there
yeah and then also the other thing
actually i found another one that i was
actually obsessed with
in the heights which is lin manuel
miranda's musical
yeah and he i went to his college and
i've seen it when
like the prototype in the heights which
is very different from what ended up on
broadway i felt in the beta version
i know and like but what i l especially
because you know i grew up in harlem
and the way he talks about washington
heights and harlem and just felt so
i just so connected with that and like
bringing that culture and that world
to a broadway stage like i remember when
i saw it for the first time and i was
just like
crying and it wasn't um
it really was probably i guess what we
would say at the time like
representation matters
right like it's like i'm not latinx but
i was like
that's my neighborhood yeah yeah to see
all these people in an audience loving
it and appreciating it
i was like this is what
we create for to bridge the gap
that's beautiful stop me oh yeah those
are my two
oh that's good to know and uh when you
have an experience like that yeah
unforgettable
uh someone to know what is your worst
corona chronicles experience
and for people that don't know what
corona chronicles are
okay this is just yeah i started doing
instagram stories
charting charting you know the moment we
got into quarantine i said
you know what can i do uh i'm never
doing comedy
like what are my options um and then
also just wanting to i say it charts one
woman's descent
into madness as her roots grow out yes
all right so if you really start from
the beginning because they are saved to
highlights honey
grace i got a bang going i got a nice
bend
here we are 130 days in i'm not even
showing you this [ __ ]
okay i'm giving you gypsy on the
uh atlantic city pier
and so it so the worst like
just things that happened right as we
kind of go i think the worst for me was
when
it was um pandemic patty is what i'm
calling her
yes when i went to pick up like a csa
box you know like a
veggies and stuff from a local
restaurant and they have a whole system
where it's like
you know you place your order you know
when it's ready you drive up
you call them and you're like i'm here
and then they will place your box
outside right so no contact so
there are people outside standing and
waiting i'm staying in the car
and i call she goes okay we're getting
your stuff she's like putting it out
i see her come and put it out so i get
out of my car
i walk to the box grace
this young white home
approaches me literally two inches from
my damn thing
and you know the rule is six yeah
no comes up also she's not wearing a
mask so this is like before like this is
early days when
it wasn't really mandated sure but she
comes in
and she's like she's like excuse me i
think that's my box of stuff
now grace not only do they
say your name like you know out to the
world whoever before they put it
there is a sign like on the receipt they
have your name
big letters right yeah and it's also
like you know me i'm naomi
and i never bother spelling my last name
because i'm like i don't feel like i'm
tired
i do that i'm like there's no other nail
me eat you know what i mean like there's
nothing
she came up and i like you know i'm so
like
thrown by someone being close to me that
i just kind of jump back yeah
and then she opens like she like
lifts the top of this the bag like this
on top of the box to like look inside to
see if those are items
and then i just start pointing at the
receipt where my name is
yeah because i was trying to talk to her
but i also didn't want to get close
look at it yeah and so i'm just like
pointing and i'm like naomi
me they owe me me like you're talking to
an animal
at that point fully fully
um and that was like the work because i
just laughed at that moment where i was
like
not simply like okay you're in my face
and you're in my space but it was also
this moment of like
oh my god am i like afraid of people now
yeah
you know what you're like are we on the
point of this where i'm afraid of other
humans
being nearby a hundred percent yeah i i
question
the uh like dissolving of all my social
skills that i've worked so hard
to get over the years that are like
fully gone
i know i know the podcast is helping
though right it's helping you
like look people in the eye and totally
remember
what sentences sound like out loud right
i mean i
i would say that you um you won
that interaction in terms of like the
right thing for a human being to do
uh okay matthew says i love naomi ask
her what
what are the three things that jubu does
that make her laugh the most
okay that's so funny so
what makes me almost angie you know how
like when you get in a relationship and
you start to just like
do stupid stuff with each other you're
comfortable yeah
yes and like especially i think because
we are
like i say like over 10 years i have
like turned andy into a strong black
woman
like the thing that will always make me
laugh like if i'm saying something or
doing something and
usually it's because i'm like not
letting him finish i tend to interrupt
him and i'll be like i know what you're
gonna say right
and he goes and it kills him he goes
girl
girl and he says like he really like
gets
he like girls me to get me to stop he
has sass
yeah yes and it cracks me up every time
like when he goes
girl girl i'm not punished and i'm
like i'm like okay fair i'm like okay go
ahead
so that definitely kills me at all times
and then
he will often talk to the animals
um as though they can understand him and
that i find
very you know that tickles me yeah it
really tickles yeah yeah
at one point i remember this he goes
and he said it dead serious like he
didn't realize it when he said it
because like the cat
like knocked something off the desk you
know how sometimes they'll just like bat
something you know yeah like knocked
over like a cup of tent to something
stupid
and i was like and i'm like andy he's
not supposed to be on the desk
and andy goes i told him not to
when i looked and i go you told
the animal and you thought
he understood you like amazing amazing
those are my two and then of course
whenever like
i don't know what does crack me up i
don't know those two are pretty dang
good
those are great um thank you okay here's
the last
question uh ambrose said
that you're his favorite and uh
wants to know advice on a friendship
becoming romantic
oh were you and your jubu
friends first we were not super long
like maybe
six months a little less but yeah we
were definitely friends
was it was interesting because i
definitely didn't think he was
interested in me because he was
at the time very repressed i've now
pulled his heart out and now we're able
to look at it and talk about it
but at the time he was very buttoned up
so i didn't
know and so i definitely um didn't like
flirt like i didn't talk to him thinking
i was trying to make something happen
um but i think i think the way
if okay if you're trying to make it
happen i think it's about like a little
physical affection you know what i mean
like a little taking of the hand the
little
lower back touch you know you want them
to like you're trying to like
connect those wires you know what i mean
like yeah your friend
is sensual you want to just really make
that connection
now if you're already together and it's
like okay what are we doing it feels
like we're being too friendly
i think it's like one of the things i
feel like i had to stop doing
i like like to tease people and roast
them uh-huh
and i realize that like when you're
trying to be romantic you have to like
stop that at some point
yeah you know what i mean yeah people
are sensitive to it
and i i'd same thing that i see that
as like a sign of affection if i'm
making fun of you but a lot of
people don't see it that way it's
important to learn they have to learn
and especially i think
i think at least i found like guys
like cis head dudes like when it's
coming from a woman and they're like
wait a minute i'm offended by this yeah
yeah you have to be like
look you're pretty i like you
totally i think that's great advice uh
and like very sincere very authentic and
very helpful
um grace you are very affirming i wish
you were a therapist
oh girl uh me too i would save money on
buying my own um this has been so
wonderful thank you for talking with us
today
before you leave usually when we do the
podcast in person we
give our guests a personalized fortune
cookie for making time for us
but because we're doing it digitally we
have a digital fortune cookie that i
believe melissa
sent to your email yes which and i don't
want to close our zoom
on my phone so i'm going to go to this
other thing up you're traveling we're
traveling
we're moving i love it we're moving
i'm going to like get this up i want to
see my digi fortune cookie
i love okay we believe that your
commentary on local children's dance
recitals
should become not just a regular but
public performance
one fortune cookie is guaranteed to
subscribe and support on patreon for
very
little money yes yes wow
i would sign up for the patreon of you
watching videos of
uh young women's dance recitals and
reviewing them
uh for everyone uh it's wonderful
thank you so much i do have a lot of hot
takes i am invested
i'm invested in child stars children
like what i can sense too that they're
bringing a professionalism
yes i'm gonna give them a professional
critique yes yeah okay
treat them like the adults that they are
keep the adults they wanna be
i love it naomi thank you so much where
can people find everything that you're
working on everything that you're doing
if they don't already know
if you enjoy laughter and fun combos
like this come to couples therapy
podcast
coupletherapypod.com um there's a couple
there a couple other podcasts with the
title
go with the picture that looks kind of
like me
and uh instagram is my new safe space so
you can come to
instagram.com at black dress comedy now
guys i used to have a day job i had to
be on the low
hence black dress comedy but we talk we
live we laugh we love
we love it make sure please check out
everything that naomi's doing it is
wonderful
it's a beautiful light in these weird
dark times i appreciate
it so so much and thank you for taking
the time to talk to us today this was so
fun
thank you for talking to me you were
just two great grace
oh this is good for us this is very good
for us
uh we'll see you guys next time on
another episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music